[Music]
welcome back guys another episode JK
news but today we're doing a little bit
of a my the [ __ ] if you've never seen
a video with us doing this before
basically this is where people unready
to post their experiences of life and
they asked us the Internet to judge them
and that's what we do we're gonna judge
them that's all we know wrong quarter so
join in with us let us know what you
think in the comments are they the
[ __ ] are they not but I'm gonna read
a little story and then you guys this
says am I the [ __ ] for firing an
employee after his parents died oh so it
says I am the VP of a sales compass ails
at a software company and one of our
sales development reps parents passed
away at the beginning of April sadly
they were involved in a car crash and
both lost their lives now the employee
in question is a very young 22 year old
guy and has been with us for about 10
months now
he's a great employee and we were
thinking about promotions in the next
six months for him his job is high
paying for what a new grad he makes
about 90 K with Commission damn days so
we expect a lot from this position
because of the accident we let him take
a month of paid leave of absence from
work
okay that was going to be my solution
yeah he returned a few weeks ago and his
performance is severely lacking he's
super unmotivated not cold calling out
reaching the prospects for the last two
to three weeks ever since he's come back
our whole management team has noticed
this and we decided to let him go
because we feel like he need months and
months to be able to produce again which
is true we called him into a meeting on
Friday afternoon and gave him the bad
news he was Friday that's nice on Friday
and the week no cool off over the
weekend he was very calm and rude about
us told us to go [ __ ] ourselves and got
up and then went to the desk grabbed a
few of his things and left I thought
this was very unprofessional industry
news 22 right I told my boyfriend about
all this and he said myself and the
management team are a bunch of [ __ ]
pricks with no heart yeah am I the
[ __ ]
well depression doesn't have a time
limit you can't be like well after
exactly a month you should be exactly
back but the business does have
that's the hard part is that we do live
in you know caliber yeah and that's how
our economy works and you need to have
your employees especially they're making
that much money being assets right
because there's an obligation right
because I mean put it let's put it into
perspective of a of a surgeon what if a
surgeon was going through depression in
the hospital gave him that month leave
he can't he comes back and he's
performing kind of lackluster on another
human's life he should have been laid
off right let me tell you what I would
do because I have a bigger heart than
you okay I would have pulled this
employee in and and warned them that we
think we've noticed that they're they're
not as motivated not working as hard
pick it up [ __ ] yeah opportunity is my
mind I assumed that that was already
there me too so if they didn't then I
think that is the [ __ ] clients move
though after that if they still didn't
improve would be to say okay take some
more time off but unpaid because they
they paid for that one month you could
have like months a couple months more
unpaid if you want and then you could
come back to your job yeah I just think
that like if that was the surgeon right
and you're the surgeon and I'm my hey
man like you put a guy's foot on his
hand but it's fine we'll figure it out
but like I need you to do a little
better okay if it's fine we're not
working out here's something that I did
actually within this company for Brandon
right so Jesus Brandon Brandon's grandma
was oh yeah I remember getting close to
being you know passing like we didn't we
we didn't know what's gonna happen and
then he he was back to fall work he was
working on some stuff and I heard that
she just got in the hospital and then he
says is it okay if I use this weekend to
cram on the work and then pass off the
work to so-and-so
and I told him no that's not okay I told
him you need to go to freaking in San
Francisco right now so I said you booked
the ticket now and I'll just fit we're
all we're gonna figure out what to do
because the work is oh like it doesn't
matter and if he were to wait over the
weekend and do it he would have missed
out on seeing his grandma for the last
time so he was able to catch her yeah
and
and he saw her and then I said spend
some time out with your family to mourn
and throughout that whole process we
still paid him and when he came back I
didn't expect him to be a high performer
but for him the situation was a little
bit different because I think the the
appreciation that he had for what we did
it just back kicked in and he became
even more motivated yeah so but in this
case I think I'd leave it open where
it's like alright dude you're awesome
and I know you're just going through
some stuff right now but you're always
welcome back yeah exactly
but he might be the [ __ ] that just
said well [ __ ] you and walk away you
know I don't know it's so hard to say
that and then they still said [ __ ] you
then then they're the [ __ ]
before we move on or continue on with
that story I was giggling a little
earlier when Joe was like you know
presenting his story about Brandon
situation and the reason why I was
giggling is that in his head he sounded
hella professional but I witnessed it as
a third person I was like yeah man you
know my grandma was the one who like
raised me and you know like she was the
one that actually told me to make the
job to move down to LA and like pursue
my dreams right and then he was like
yeah like I heard she just got into the
hospital and I was like you know I have
like a lot of work to do right and she
cried and proposed that plan to Joe and
then Joe was like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you got a table like you know I
really care about you Brandon yeah
don't probably halfway through brand
stories like my grandma's been so cool
like she'd really she raised me since I
was a kid all of a sudden Joe's like and
then he's like whoa whoa I'm taking to
something else but because the Joe guy
aggressive is like what the [ __ ] is
doing here man
family first get the [ __ ] out of here go
home I don't [ __ ] care
I love Joe's way of loving people though
I don't remember things accurately but
it's the point in the purpose the
principle yeah yeah I think in this
story like I like nice guy Steve corner
or wrist use like I'm more compassionate
let me confess you're a bigger heart
than Joe
well we'll have to touch base with nice
guy Steve for like everything for that
hot take but I don't think that okay I
feel like the person writing this they
would have written hey we gave him a
warning I don't think that happened I
think that this person didn't have the
strength to communicate to this guy
whose parents had just died
they made a decision forum yeah the
opportunity to like wrap it up and then
change and fix yeah it came abruptly
that's what context is missing yeah they
gave him multiple chances did that ever
happen cuz if not then yes you are the
[ __ ] yeah definitely seems like they
would have included it for sure right
yeah so much extra detail already that
we probably already didn't I guess in
yeah for me I just assumed that they did
it cuz that's kind of like standard
protocol in my mind
yeah my I just figured oh yeah we
already gave him the month we don't need
to like talk about anymore that was his
chance employees they're talking [ __ ] to
like God how much time does he need well
your we're gonna ass off like I smoked a
pack of 50 today yeah
hello we didn't know it but just gonna
head
my old man was the boss of like this
Medical Supply Company and one of his
employees like I don't know what
happened in his life but all of a sudden
like he went from being a stellar
employee to like showing up smelling
like alcohol and [ __ ] mmm and my dad
gave the guy like nine chances like [ __ ]
like this sometimes you can go too far
you're like I just want to get in heaven
so whatever maybe this will help out
like sure like that you can you couldn't
also be taken for a rivalry sure but
then what it's funny because my dad
ended up having the fire of the guy
right and then the guy because of that
life change getting fired not having
your job anymore like having that
resistance all of a sudden he ended up
like like becoming a cop and like he
came back and thanked my dad and said
that was the best thing that ever
happened from drunk to cop right damn
yeah does that make you feel better no
no there's a drunk cop out there I feel
even better because I know there's a
gang member cops out there
why are missing an officer whiskey was
bad enough what is fingers become common
I know X gang members that still well
they were getting their gang member
tattoos covered up and then they changed
their life join the military he did all
this stuff and then they became officers
so did they know or against the bus or
like where their hideouts wearing all
that [ __ ] I don't know they knew the
culture you just get stitches no I like
those ones where like the police go and
they hire a person that used to be yeah
yeah like they there's this one guy that
was doing YouTube videos that he stole
like millions of dollars in jewels and
jewelry and then please hired him I'd
like to help them understand like break
hands and chin cuz he knows all of that
sacker as they do that with the luck
when the cops are gonna hire us to make
a YouTube channel right right that's
really keep getting work because I go to
companies that haven't gone into the new
media sphere and I have what they need
so to us we have we're like we do
YouTube but everyone wants what we have
we see cops doing social media pose
that's for damn sure
social
it's why dude any of you guys right now
could run the Instagram for LAPD
trust me I know a lot of jokes fire too
fast I know too many ex tubers who are
doing that now ex tubers it's true and
I'm like damn you guys forgot like big
YouTube channels they just got to like a
TK or something like let me see those on
Amazon like how to start a YouTube
channel I would I would type that in to
see what's out there and there's people
with like 20,000 subscribers that's like
look how we found our YouTube seen those
channels they have like 20,000
subscribers and they're like we're doing
a meet-up and then the next video is
like no one showed up at our meetup oh
my oh it's great but those are those
people that are like the the Mia my
garage guy that make a life out of
teaching people how to do anything that
they don't really know how to do yet but
they're just really convincing they're
like here's the steps 1 through 5 on how
to start a successful YouTube channel
just like ours 567 views those who can't
do teach as they say I had an
ex-boyfriend like that
he just redone of personal development
books and then he tried to be a
motivational speaker but he had never
had any success of his own he just read
all the information yeah I did it to be
motivated yeah so it's funny if you're a
small tuber because remember I remember
we used to do meetups and [ __ ] yeah
always catch but can you imagine being a
small tube you're like let's do a
meet-up and then you're in a public
place like we used to be like some some
outdoor mall area and and as people walk
through you're like oh you're here for
the meter oh are you here for them you
okay you definitely alright
it's me it's me you know me it's me oh
hey guys it's now that was playlist it
was so [ __ ] funny though we were there
for a meet up but nobody [ __ ] came in
we're next to a hugely popular channel
for 12 year olds or something like 12
year old Jojo sua somebody with blue
hair and swoopy and their whole it was
like this so they split up the the the
convention or the the hall right and and
it's like all these empty rolls a seat
was for us and we were even sharing it
with another guy I don't even know what
the [ __ ] was happening but there was
this another one and it was all [ __ ]
full dude that's what happened one year
at playlist in DC they put us on a panel
with family vloggers it was like I'm
with family vloggers and so it was like
shaycarl like oh like really Batali or
they all dojo family bought a channels
and then they did a thing with a
shaycarl ski before this was like 2016
or 15 or something and so then they have
a part where the where the audience gets
to come up and you know go down the line
and get autographs and we're at the end
of the breath like the second-to-last
and so they go down the line and they're
like oh my god I love this video when
you do this can you sign this P that's
so personal both and each one oh my god
I love you well if you're so good at
this video you could make my day every
day and then they looked at us like oh
yeah there was a mixup
like a pity autograph that are there or
now wow they're good yeah you tonight
what's your channel and I'm like oh it
says Nikki Lima I was like you're fine I
don't know I'll look it up
[Music]
[Music]